ich predige das jetzt seit 5 Jahren dass
man schwarz Kümmelöl nehmen sollte wir
haben gefiltert und ungefiltert da und
viele Fragen was ist der unterschied
hier ist das ungefilterte das muss ja
jetzt eigentlich schwarz sein wenn ihr
es jetzt ausgießt zeige ich euch einfach
direkt mal ungeschüttelt ist die Farbe
so wie beim gefilterten Öl ich zeig's
euch richtig schön Gold ne schütteln
einmal und jetzt sind die schweb und
Trübstoffe die hier unten sich
abgelagert haben einfach mit dem Öl
vermischt und daher ist es jetzt
komplett schwarz wenn ihr mich fragt was
sollt es ist wirklich persönliche
Präferenz das hier schmeckt ein bisschen
schärfer ein bisschen intensiver das
gefilterte Öl schmeckt einfach milder
ich nehme seit 5 Jahren das hier es gibt
aber auch viele die Sagen n wenn schon
denn schon aber die Auswirkungen sind
komplett identisch